[Music]
foreign
[Music]
time you like to you like to bust it out
I mean I'd love to start at the
beginning I just you know I haven't had
my morning cigar yet John so every day
with those things yeah I don't inhale
them no man I still work out every day I
just like to smoke are you not buying
you don't box at Steve's anymore it's
too far I used to live in Larchmont I
used to drive right down right to
Steve's Petra Molly's yeah it's it's it
was fought 10 minutes from my house what
what about uh I just talked to him on
the phone man he sends love that's
awesome he's one of a kind huh yeah he
is he's the best and he loves do you
know that like Steve at that gym like
like no [ __ ] 85 percent of the
people that box of that gym he kicks out
like if he if he had more tolerant of
people that were full of [ __ ] I didn't
know that he would make all the money in
the world but like he literally he won't
let people in that gym because like if
you lie once if you don't if you don't
if you if you don't be who you say you
are once you can't box out I get that
about him and he was like he was like I
I just got off the phone with him Sammy
is one of okay he's like I love that guy
he's one of a [ __ ] you know where
that is for Steve to say that it's like
I literally I can't say that Steve
really said that said it to me on the
day he goes yeah I tell him he told me
what story did he ask me to oh he said
that you were uh
you were holding hand pads for him yeah
you would you told your lady about that
he has old man strength and it reminded
you of some store what was what was that
it says there's some store where you
like fought an old guy in the pan or
something yeah that was the toughest
fight I ever met in my life tell me okay
so the year was uh 2006 yeah
I was in Dixon Correctional Center in
Dixon Illinois okay and
2000 how old are you 2006. 23. so
I'm 39 now so the only reason oh this is
a trip I haven't thought about this
story in a long time he's probably the
last person I told that story to yeah
worm Big Worm so check this out
so the only reason I got Dixon was the
sweetest joint in the state when I say
sweet
what I mean is you had the most movement
you could do you could you could move
around you could do whatever you wanted
to do and the only reason I got to Dixon
the only [ __ ] reason
is because I had a lawsuit against IDOC
because I got they beat my [ __ ]
brains out in 2005 in Stateville behind
the wall which is which is Max they
didn't get the [ __ ] out of me right the
CEOs the CEOs and lieutenants because I
punched the white shirt in the face over
uh over the Jewish star it was actually
a high got it really got it oh I want to
hear that story too but tell me tell me
tell me
in any event though uh I'm not trying to
blow smoke in your face this is a
wonderful cigar though I mean this is a
really truly wonderful like this you got
to toast it so you want you want to
toast it you want to hold the flame just
just far and yeah just but a little bit
further away so just like the tip of the
flame and really toast it for like a
good minute and then just for a minute
you didn't do it I did do it a minute I
did about 40 seconds now see how I just
said you didn't do it a minute yeah you
feel like I was being aggressive no no
right it's just the way we talk right he
really is like a all right sorry tell
the story sorry sorry you just want to
talk a cigar like this you really want
to toast it I'm only busting this out
for a special occasion because it's you
honest to God I would [ __ ] smoke a
regular thank you bro you know regular
like ten dollar cigar but you got you
know I busted out the big guns for you
thank you bro but isn't that like
somebody you know what's crazy though
isn't it like when you're already a
superstar you get all the best [ __ ] do
you know what I mean isn't that true
though right I mean it's it's uh I I
have noticed like the people who need it
yeah I could have brought you a 15 cigar
but instead I'm like nah it's burnt
though but I'm gonna bring a 75.60 but
you know what's [ __ ] up about it is
you could have brought me the [ __ ]
you would have been happy with four
dollars I would have been happy and I
wouldn't have known the difference I
mean I mean but I'll enjoy this and it
says a lot about you you know the
difference it says a lot about you that
says a lot about you all right so Dixon
Dixon Correctional what's the
dormitories like in Dixon so it's not
they're not dorms their cells but here's
the thing so
I was truly uh a very bad behaved inmate
the entire time I was in prison and the
only reason I got to Dixon the only
people that got to Dixon were were guys
had been locked up 20 years and had
already like worked their way through
the system and good behavior got down
there or yeah or like cops that got
locked up or something like that and it
was it was people that had been locked
up a long time it was not a play because
it was a a medium security prison and I
was somebody that had spent five and a
half years out of eight and a half years
in solitary confinement disciplinary
segregation
so I was never going to end up in Dixon
the only reason I got down there is
because after I got into it with the
white shirt with the lieutenant and they
beat the [ __ ] out I mean they knocked my
tooth out they you know they gave me a
pumpkin head Deluxe they really they
[ __ ] me up real bad I never gave up
hope of coming out from under they gave
me a year solitary confinement uh a year
good time loss which means you have to
do a extra year added on to your
sentence and then on top of that they
were gonna try to give me a case so to
combat that I started writing law uh
writing lawyers in the law library every
[ __ ] day I would write a different
lawyer right and so I amassed like 50
letters that I sent out and I got
represented from a law firm a pretty
pers you know prestigious law what was
the basis of your case like what what
were you what were you excessive force
excessive force I punched this guy I did
and then
after they hit me with the old the uh
the pepper spray right in my face and
and I got one punch off and then they
beat the [ __ ] out of me and then they
got me we're in a little so in
Stateville yeah on on eight Gallery you
know what I mean it's it's four stories
up and they beat the [ __ ] out of me got
me on the ground handcuffed me and then
stomped me out stopped me in the nuts
stopped me how many guys uh five five it
was two white shirts and three uh CEOs
tell everybody what a white shirt is a
white shirt is a lieutenant a white
shirt is a lieutenant he wears a white
shirt and that and that was so that was
over the high
that was over the necklace okay all
right you gotta tell us that story too
I'll tell you that story too but but to
get the the Dixon fight I just say that
because I got down to Dixon because of
the lawsuit they let me down in this
prison and I never would have been there
and as soon as I got down there I got
into a fight which I'm not going to get
into that I just got into another fight
over some some gang banging [ __ ] but
regardless
time goes by and when you're in when
you're in in prison on the back of the
IDLC cards it says staff assaulter if
you've it says your religion and it says
if you've ever assaulted a staff it will
say staff assaulter right and like back
then it was like but back then it was
like a badge of honor but the only thing
is is like if COC that [ __ ] they're
gonna [ __ ] with you yeah they're gonna
[ __ ] with you big time right
wish you another story what
so the thing happened is this is good
isn't it a good cigar yeah so
essentially a new warden came down and
he started uh instituting some [ __ ] up
policies
like more lockdown and things like that
and guys were all pissed off and I was
pissed off right so what kicked the
whole thing off is we were sitting at
the chow hall and they were bigger
tables at the chow hall right there was
like in in Dixon there was a lot of guys
at the table
and I'm sitting there and I was talking
to myself I was like these CEO said
something like he was taught I think he
might have been rushing us to to hurry
up our food or whatever and he's like
you know he's telling us to go and I
just sat down and ate I'm like man these
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] and this dude
next to me who was an old guy named worm
his real name I remember his real name
Charles Wormley he was locked up for
murdering a cop when he was a kid in the
70s and he had been locked up since the
70s right I would never remember details
like that but on this guy I remember and
uh and he was a cool dude but regardless
um
so
he hears me mumbling like these [ __ ]
ass [ __ ] and he goes he like
tries to from me off he's like
he's like why don't you do something
about it then man he's like if if you're
so if you're so mad about it why don't
you get up and throw a tray in his face
then you know and he started like
Instagram in front of people
and at that time in my life I did not
like making any scenes in front of
anybody right and uh and by the way the
politics in Chicago and Illinois are
very different than the politics out
here uh in the prison system can you
explain I can there's no race in Chicago
because all the gangs are you got you
got black dudes and Latino games you got
white dudes and Latino gangs you've got
Latino dudes and black gangs you've got
some white guys in Black gangs it's very
different very different and that's how
it is in the in the joint right whereas
out here obviously you know the politics
cars are all you know One race and
everything like that but
so nonetheless
we're sitting at the same table
and the guy starts I've never had an
interaction with this dude in my life
right so the dude's like
why don't you get up and do something
about it so I'm looking and I don't say
nothing
because I'm not because at that time in
my life
it was dry snitching in my mind if I say
anything and make a scene that's dry
snitching because you're you're you're
alerting the CEOs that there could be
that there could be some type of
altercation probably gonna do that so I
just I didn't say [ __ ] to him
and then everybody got off at the table
he stayed sitting I stayed sitting And
when everybody got up
I took my idea I showed a staff so I
said I said [ __ ] I've been doing
this [ __ ] that's who I first of all I
didn't know anything about this guy I
didn't know that this dude you know had
was locked up for 40 [ __ ] years and
liked it and he was getting ready to go
see the parole board I didn't know any
of this [ __ ] but I'm just like I said I
said why don't you go do something I
said you know what [ __ ] you go
do go go hit the seal right now I'll
follow suit to you how about that how
about that
and he started talking [ __ ] I said you
know I told myself I was I said you know
you know [ __ ] here's my cell
come holler at me afterwards come I'm
not gonna make a I'm not gonna
[ __ ] make a scene in front of
the police [ __ ] come see me
after you know when we get back so
um
we get back I go on my cell I told my
next door neighbor I said Hey listen man
I got into his [ __ ] in the chow
hall if you see a dude coming down the
gallery let me know and he's like all
right all right and or it's a wing it's
a wing in in Dixon because they're
they're Wings on the on this on the unit
galleries are in the cell houses in uh
Stateville in the max so nonetheless
uh I'm in there I'm I'm you know putting
my shoes on I'm getting ready and uh my
neighbor my next door neighbor whose
name was Big T he called me say hey bro
he goes uh dude's coming and he and
dude's coming he's got gloves on he
looks he's mugged the [ __ ] up he's no
clothes on like you got he wrapped his
hands
like guys wear
um
like gardening gloves they sell on
commissary so they don't get marks on
their fist because if you get into a
fight and somebody snitches then
Internal Affairs will look at your fist
to try to see if you have Marsh on your
fist and then they'll take you to jail
they'll take but your hands still get
marked up right with them
they're looking for literally yeah
they're looking for red marks along the
knuckles you know and all that so uh oh
my bad so uh whatchamacallit
so uh
Big D says a dude coming down right now
like he's he's all he's all mugged up
and and got gloves on and I'm like all
right cool so now
it was cool to [ __ ] the the wings
were about as wide as this
wooden area right here right cell doors
on each side and so all the guys made a
wall so we had like a legit area to
fight right and
I don't remember who threw the first
punch but
all I remember is when Dude hit me I'll
never forget this [ __ ] because when Dude
hit me
my [ __ ] eyes went like this in
my brain
wow right
he hit me with like a two-piece crispy
yeah and my eyes were just like
and we got into it yeah and we and we
went at it yeah you know for like a good
I don't know maybe it felt like 10
minutes it was probably a minute right
we got into it yeah and like I had like
a little busted lip he had a little
busted lip we it was what it was and uh
because I remember the whole week
I was walking like this when my lips
sucked in so nobody would see it so if I
was ever walking to the child hall or
anywhere I was going
I had my lip sucked in so that the CEOs
wouldn't see that I had a mark from
fighting right yeah uh injury
and we never got caught for that fight
right we got we got away with it and
that was the one guy literally in all
the fights that got into which was quite
a few
that I talked to after the like
afterwards we were cool it was like a
mutual respect like he was just cool and
then I found out this dude had been
locked up since he was like [ __ ] 15
he got charged as an adult for a a a
murder when he was like 15 this dude was
like a c number and C numbers still see
the parole board in Illinois they cut
your at the time they cut your time in
half and you don't see a parole board no
more you just if you don't get in
trouble you get out at a certain date
but the guys that were locked up before
1978 I think were still C numbers and
those guys still see the parole board to
this day wow if there's any alive still
which I think there's probably a few
um
so I say that because
he was getting ready to go see the
parole board and so I imagine he was
stressed the [ __ ] out yeah you know so
anyways that's the worm story and I told
that to Petra Molly because I remember
when worm hit me
to this day I've never been well
actually I have my boy down the bomb
George she hits as hard as worm he's a
[ __ ] monster but uh
when when worm it was the toughest fight
I was ever in like the way that he
punched me in my face I I remember
thinking like oh I'm you know I'm in for
some [ __ ] but that was a jail fight so I
was hitting him with bows you should eat
them in the stomach and you felt that
you felt that power with Steve yeah I
felt that power Steve Steve he's crazy
he's got the old message it's incredible
so I thought I was holding the Mist for
him and the [ __ ] hits my mitt
and I'm like all right you got some
[ __ ] old man screaming and he's
fast yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean he's a
good guy yeah and I told him the word I
think I told him like an Abridged
version of that story yeah he loved this
so and and but at that point when you're
locked up had you already had Pro fights
that was all after yeah it was all after
it was all after man
[Music]
foreign
[Music]